when
you cultivate and nourish that thing
that is bringing you Joy and you pay
attention to the subtle voices that are
telling you this feels right when you
commit to that completely
that will set you on a journey that will
lead you to a place you can't possibly
imagine when I put on the running shoes
for the first time and just thought I
love doing this
could I have imagined that I'd be
sitting across from you right now having
a conversation it's ridiculous it's
preposterous
so
what I learned was
the power of connecting with the heart
as somebody like yourself who lives in
their mind and Prides themselves on
their intellect and their analytic
abilities understanding the limitations
of that and finding a way to really pay
attention to those kind of more
ephemeral ethereal messages